- [Narrator] Tucked away in Budapest,
Vajdahunyad Castle is medieval
in look but not in age.
(airy electronic music)
Built in 1896, this architectural
complex was designed
to celebrate the first millennium
of the Hungarian state.
The buildings were
supposed to be temporary,
so they were made of wooden
planks and cardboard designs.
But Hungarians loved them so much,
they were rebuilt with permanent
materials in the 1900s.
The celebratory site
features copies of landmarks
from all over the larger
19th-Century Hungarian kingdom,
combining architectural
details of 21 buildings,
like the Romanesque Church of Yak,
originally located in western Hungary;
or the Vajdahunyad, or Corvin Castle,
located in what is now Romania,
and more commonly known to
fans of the Dracula myth.
It's believed that Vlad the Impaler
was once imprisoned there.
The name of the Romanian
Castle ended up being adopted
by Budapestians for the whole compound.
Several Austrian palaces
are represented, as well,
featuring a blend of Renaissance
and Baroque architecture,
demonstrating the diversity of styles
that spread across the
Austria-Hungarian Empire.
And just like the castles
it's built to imitate,
Vajdahunyad is built to be defended.
It's accessible only by four bridges,
stretching across the surrounding lake.
For over a century, the castle
has continued to be enjoyed
by Budapestians and tourists alike
who come to relish in this
truly Hungarian artifact.
(poppy electronic music)